BEFORE THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
WE HAVE FOX TEAM COVERAGE
TONIGHT.
JOHN ROBERTS AT THE WHITE HOUSE
WITH WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS
SAYING AND DOING ABOUT ALL OF
THIS.
OFF WITH CHEAP CONGRESSIONAL
CORRESPONDENT MIKE MANUAL ON
CAPITOL HILL WITH ME WITH THE
LATEST ON TODAY'S BIG MEETING.
WERE KEEPING IN MIND THE MEETING
WERE KEEPING IN MIND THE MEETIN
MEETING.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT SPEAKS, HE'S
EXPECTED TO SPEAK AFTER THE
MEETING, WE WILL BRING YOU THOSE
REMARKS.
>> GOOD EVENING.
PRESIDENT TRUMP PUSHING HOUSE
REPUBLICANS TO GET THIS DONE,
PASSING IMMIGRATION REFORM PLAN
THIS WEEK.
FOXES LEARNED THE COMPROMISE
BILL THAT THE HOUSE LEADERSHIP
HAS CRAFTED WOULD TAKE STEPS TO
ADDRESS THE PARENT AND CHILD
BEING SEPARATED AT THE
BORDER ISSUE, WHAT IS BECOME THE
CRITICAL TOPIC HERE ON
CAPITOL HILL.
>> IF YOU HAPPEN TO BE A POOR
PERSON, WE'RE GOING TO YANK THAT
BABY OUT OF THE MOTHER'S ARMS.
>> DEMOCRATS BLASTING
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR BLAMING
CONGRESS OVER PARENTS BEING
SEPARATED FROM THEIR CHILDREN.
>> THAT IS A LOAD OF CRAP.
IT REALLY IT'S JUST WRONG.
GIVE ME A BREAK.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT.
>> SENATOR REPUBLICAN LEADERS
ARE HOPEFUL THEY CAN ADDRESS THE
NARROW ISSUE AS SOON AS THIS
WEEK.
>> WE ARE GOING TO FIX THE
PROBLEM.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS WE NEED TO
ACT.
DEMOCRATS SAY WE NEED TO ACT AND
WE SAY WE NEED TO ACT.
WHEN THAT HAPPENS, WE ACT.
>> >> ON A DEMOCRATIC LEADER SA
>> >> ON A DEMOCRATIC LEADER SS
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD HANDLE IT.
>> HIM MR. PRESIDENT, I WILL
LEND YOU MY PEN, ANY PEN.
YOU CAN FIX IT YOURSELF.
>> ORRIN HATCH CIRCULATING A
LETTER CALLING FOR A PAUSE ON
FAMILY SEPARATIONS UNTIL
CONGRESS HAS TIME TO PASS A
LEGISLATIVE FIX.
HATCH ARGUES FAMILY SHOULD NOT
HAVE TO SUFFER WHILE CONGRESS
TAKES THE TIME TO GET THIS DONE
RIGHT.
BORDER STATE REPUBLICANS SAY
THAT THE ANSWER IS HANDLING
FAMILIES IN A SYMPATHETIC WAY.
>> WE NEED TO ENFORCE THE LAW
BUT DO SO IN A WAY THAT KEEPS
FAMILIES TOGETHER IN A HUMANE,
COMPASSIONATE WAY.
IT IS A COMPLEX PROBLEM.
NOT ENFORCING THE LAW IS NOT AN
OPTION, AT LEAST FOR ME.
>> THERE IS AT LEAST SOME
BIPARTISAN AGREEMENT.
>> IF YOU DETAIN THEM, DETAIN
THEM AS A FAMILY UNIT.
IF YOU SEND ONE BACK, SEND THEM
ALL BACK.
SENATE JUDICIARY SAYS
PRESIDENT TRUMP MUST BE ON BOARD
WITH ANY LEGISLATIVE FIX ON
IMMIGRATION.
>> THE LEADER WILL NOT BRING UP
ANY IMMIGRATION BILLS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS NOT COMMITTED
TO SIGNING.
EVEN IF WE GOT 60    60 VOTES AD
EVEN IF WE GOT 60    60 VOTES AT
EVEN IF WE GOT 60    60 VOTES AE
PRESIDENT WON'T SIGN IT, IT'S
NOT GOING TO COME UP.
>> IN HEARINGS, THE ISSUE
REMAINS A DOMINANT TOPIC.
>> ARE YOU NOT SHAKEN BY THE
VOICES AND FACES OF THE CHILDREN
TORN AWAY FROM THEIR FAMILIES?
>> OF COURSE I AM BUT I AM ALSO
SHAKEN BY THE STORIES I HEAR
ABOUT PARENTS DRAGGING THEIR
LITTLE KIDS DO THE DESERT.
>> ARE YOU AWARE --
>> THERE IS A POLITICAL
COMPONENT WHICH COULD PUT
DEMOCRATS UP FOR REELECTION IN
RED STATES IN JEOPARDY.
SENATE DEMOCRATS HAVE SIGNED
ONTO A BILL BILL OFFERED BY
CALIFORNIA'S DIANNE FEINSTEIN
WHO ADMITS IT WOULD NOT ALLOW
ARRESTS WITHIN 100 MILES OF THE
BORDER.
>> IF THAT BOTHERS SUSAN COMEAU
WILL TAKE IT OUT.
>> AND A HOUSE HEARING, THE TOP
DEMOCRATS MEET THIS APPEAL.
>> WE NEED YOU TO JOIN US AND
TELLING HIM...
THIS MEAN POLICY.
>> THE TIMING OF ALL OF THIS
HEADING INTO MIDTERM CAMPAIGN
SEASON MAKES IT A RED-HOT
POLITICAL ISSUE.
AS YOU KNOW, NOT EASY TO SOLVE.
>> Bret: THE FEINSTEIN BILL,
DOES IT HAVE A CHANCE OF GETTING
THROUGH?
POLITICALLY.
JOE DONNELLY AND HEIDI HEITKAMP
AND JON TESTER IN ALL THESE RED
STATE DEMOCRATS UP FOR
REELECTION, TO SIGN ONTO THAT
BILL, THAT IS POTENTIALLY
POLITICALLY JEOPARDIZING.
>> I HAVE TALKED TO REPUBLICAN
SOURCES WHO SAY THEY THINK THE
DEMOCRAT SENATORS WERE LOOKING
FOR AN EXIT RAMP FROM THE ISSUE.